Hi, I'm David Hornsby.
I'm Ashly Burch.
-I'm Daniel Pudi.
And we're here to
talk about our first time.
-Directing.
-Yes, directing. I’m sorry. Is that not clear?
-Yeah. Directing.
-Directing.
(Rock music)
-I definitely had
moments where I was like,
“Why do I want to
cut everything that I'm in?”
Down to as
minimal as possible.
And I was like, “Oh, it’s just
because I'm an actor.”
It's not that hard...
...Right?
It's not that hard.
You just do your thing,
and then you're
like, “A’ight. We good?
Okay. Let’s move on.”
I didn't even
yell, “Action” or “Cut”.
I don’t think I- I-
-I don’t think I did once either.
-one time yell ‘Action’ or ‘Cut’
-Really, you need to act like it’s more involved.
-Oh. Oh, shoot.
-You gotta- yeah. Maybe act like-
-Guys, this is very difficult stuff.
-Yeah, it requires some finesse.
-I'll tell the camera people here.
You guys don't
know how hard it is.
-Mr. Brittlesbee is very busy.
If you're mentally ill,
I'd be more than happy to
drive you to a nearby asylum.
-Jo, please.
What did Rob
and Megan say to you,
in terms of
advice for directing?
-Nothing.
(Laughing)
Uh... “Don’t screw it up!”
No, I don't know.
They were just
like, “You'll be fine.”
-Yeah.
(Laughter)
Rob said, “Come with a plan,
be prepared to throw it out.”
-If your gut is
right 51% of the time,
that's a good gut.
-Megan said, “Babysit,
be a good babysitter.”
-Who was she talking about?
(Laughter)
-But it was good. I
feel like I learned a lot.
It was a nice way to, like,
really appreciate and see the-
you know, how much
goes into into the show.
What about you?
-Didn't say anything.
(Laughing)
They said, “Uh, we're leaving.
If you got this,
then we're gonna go home.”
And I was like,
“Yeah, that's fine.
That’s fair. That’s fair. Go.”
How do I look?
Big time Hollywood producer?
More like, big time
Hollywood pedophile.
-What are you the most
proud of from your episode?
That it’s complete.
-I hope!  For sure.
-That my episode is done.
I'm so proud of that.
-I think I'm
gonna echo that with,
just getting it covered.
I think that there were
a few scenes where I was like,
“I just hope we
covered it all,” you know?
Like, you were in
a great scene with Rob
where you were
both improv-ing a lot about,
you know, Superman,
and flying, and shoe size.
-And would you
like to know the size?
13.
Let me see that.
Let me see that the-
oh, that is so sad.
-Now it’s too late.
-I was like,
“I hope we got it all.”
-Mm.
-Y’know?
And I think we did.
And that felt nice.
When I went and saw
with- with Josh, the editor,
And being like, “Okay,
good. It cuts together.”
-I think I'm the most proud
that during my
episode, the crew wasn’t like:
(Laughter)
-Yeah.
All right, yeah, actor directing...
Cool, cool, cool.
-Yeah.
-I mean, like...
-Did anything surprise you
when you
were, like, doing it?
-I was surprised that
I wasn't a total mess.
Honestly!
-You weren’t. You were really great.
Confident. Great. It was awesome.
-Yeah! You faked it-
You faked it very well.
-I'm gonna-
I'm gonna be a writer, Brad.
-Ugh. Yuck.
-How did you find
giving actors notes?
What's the-
what's a nice way to say
you want
something different?
-That's a good question.
I realized while I
was directing that...
I have to use less words, you know?
-Again, not to just blow
smoke up everyone’s a**.
But I never was
in the position where
I was like, “Ooh.
That just didn't work.”
It was more like,
“Oh, it would be fun to try this.”
For Imani, for example,
she had a scene
with Rob and Charlotte,
and to have a
moment of going up to her
and being like,
“You don't like Poppy,
So just play it like that.”
Like, "everything you say to her,
you don't like her. You like Ian.
You don’t like her."
And then it was just
cool to see what came out.
-Dana, Dana, Dana, Dana.
-What?!
-Hey, um, you just back me up.
-I find it's best to, like,
if you approach
an actor, you kind of-
you come low.
-Oh my God.
-Right?
You get low, and
you have a treat with you.
-Mm-hmm.
-Right?
And you
say, “Hey, I'm gonna...
...you want? You want a little?”
And then you can
say whatever you want.
But you give them the treat,
and you get
your hand away fast,
‘cause they will bite it.
And then...
And then you walk away.
And then, you
know, they'll usually do it.
I think that was- that was-
I have found the best process.
Do you guys find
that to be the case?
(Snorts)
(Silence)
-Great meeting.
-Oh, it’s ov- it’s over? Okay.
So check out our
next season of Mythic Quest.
And see if you can guess
who directed what episode.
-Without looking at the credits first.
-Yes.
(Rock music)
-Being a director on a TV show,
you want to get
everything that you need to get,
but also...
not being someone that is
keeping everyone needlessly long,
and, you know, whatever.
Like now.
-Like--
(Laughter)